what's going on guys national master james kante
the third here with chess.com and today we have
the top five world championship blunders yes
even the best of the best blunder as well in
this first example we have anatoly karpov versus
gary kasparov in the 1987 world championship match
let's see what's going on here so it's
white to move here and of course uh black's
black is attacking the rook here gary kasparov
is attacking this rook it's a lot of things going
on looks like king safety is kind of wild for a
little bit both but definitely white so anatoly
carpenter says queen takes a6 here actually now
we're eyeing g6 maybe we have this check here as
well and we're also defending g4 at the same time
here now gary these guys are both in time trouble
right now actually there's a video actually you
can find online there is a video now oh of this
exact position but what happened here is gary
looked around the board and he's like i need to
figure this out g4 would be made queen takes g4 is
definitely checkmate if i can divert this rook in
somehow some way so what does he do he diverts the
rook by playing rook a1 but at the same time it's
an absolute blunder the game is over after the
next move here and of course anatoly karpov if
you watch the video he just calmly wrote down the
move and then he looked up and he made his move no
emotion at all just made the move here queen takes
g6 and gary was like oh my goodness what did i do
i cannot believe i just gave this game away
immediately a blunder and he resigned right
after this move the reason being guys is queen g6
not only is a check but it defends the czech mate
that was here on g4 and the intention after rook
a1 was if rookie won with an obvious reasons
guys if rook takes there's pawn takes which is a
beautiful pretty mate here and also queen takes
with her both checkmate here guys they're both
checkmate but actually he chose rookie run here
because he was in time trouble time trouble gets
the best of us he chose rick a1 and queen takes g6
bam there it is now we're checking the king
also defending no matter what you do here we're
just gonna take on a1 and the game is virtually
over here guys and that was blunder number one
of the world championships now let's get
on to blunder number two okay guys now
on to blunder number two we have victor korchnoy
versus anatoly karpov in 1978 guys let's actually
see what happened here karpov plays rook to c6
kind of a wild position here actually i mean
when is the last time you've ever seen a position
like this or any time you've seen a position with
two knights in the rook versus two rooks and some
pawns very dynamic position king placements kind
of weird here maybe some mating threats especially
especially after rook to c6 threatening rook c1
checkmate on the move very very wild position
here white needs to do something he needs to
defend the check menu on a back rank and you have
a few ways to do so rather pushing the h pawn with
some left for the king pushing the g pawn with
the same idea or moving the rook back to defend
the rank here what would you do actually with
the white pieces here to defend this checkmate
if i gave you five seconds what would you choose
in this position if you were victor courchnoy
here we go guys all right now let me tell you
what the answer is the answer is actually g3 or g4
surprising right it seems like you would
push the h pawn but you actually get
mated by pushing the h-bond so g3 or g4
is actually the only move in this position
and victor courchnoy chose
rook to a1 and that my friend
is not a move it is a complete blunder right
here can you find the move the sequence that
uh our anatoly karpov played in his position to
win the game guys black to move what would you do
here we go guys look at this next move oh my
goodness knight f3 check whoa knight f3 check
i can just take the knight can't i i can just take
the knight well what about king h1 what if i just
move my king over well then hey just have a nice
day smothered mate this is beautiful this is going
into books for everyone to see for history right
so this is just not fun to play that at all victor
cautionoid knew that this hurt here and he had to
take the knight he was actually he was forced to
resign in this position but this is was actually
what it was if if we do see pawn takes knight um
on f3 here well what's the next move class here
we are here it is always check it might be made
check there it is the king has to go somewhere
you only have one move to go to and after king h1
oh my goodness mate with the knights so beautiful
the pieces were so beautifully placed here rk1 was
such a blunder but it's not an easy blunder it
wasn't just like a huge blunder it was just hard
to see was one of the blunders that like i didn't
know it was a blunder rook a1 looks perfectly fine
until you play anatoly karpov who says think again
think again okay think again here that was blunder
number two guys that really hurts here and the
only way to get out of this was actually g3
or g4 so if there are any checks you kind of just
have to run the king away and somehow some way
maybe even giving up one of the rigs
for the night and hoping for a draw
fighting for a draw here because the pieces are
placed very nicely here what an amazing checkmate
by anatoly karpov here back in 1978 in this
world championship match guys that was blunder
number two and now let's move on to blender
number three now we move on to blunder number
three world championship blunder number three in
this game we have david bronstein versus mikhail
botvinik in 1951 guys all right so let's
check this out now it's actually black to
move here right now mikhail bapunic says i'm
going to queen my pawn i'm going to queen
there is an extra knight here and right here
you have to stop this pawn from queening right
or you're just going to lose the game david
bronstein understands that here so he's trying
to figure out the best way to do this now what
would you play in david bronstein's shoes here
how do you actually stop this pawn is there
a way to stop this pawn what would you do
well here we go guys the best move and best
sequence is actually knight to e6 followed
by knight to d4 and we just stopped upon pretty
simple and actually ends up being some type of
draw here but white wants more lights up a piece
and he wants to win this game so what he chooses
is actually king to c2 which is actually a full
on game over blunder now what bronstein expected
right here actually was what guys let's actually
see if you can figure that out black to move
mikhail bob and nick you're playing bob venice
shoes here what do you think you should do
what do you think you should do what would be
your your your number one move what would that be
here it is guys actually david bronstein and many
other players here were actually expecting king to
f3 and if king to f3 then knight comes in and if
king f2 are pushing the pawn doesn't matter how
you do it we're putting knight to d4 and we're
just going to take the pawn here pretty simple
here right but mikhail baphanix says haha i don't
have to go king f3 i don't have to go king f3
at all he actually plays this right here king to
g3 shocked david brunstein didn't even believe he
was like is that it even a real move is it even
legal it's there the game ends on the spot right
here guys the game was over as we finish it out
here king to g3 now after king g3 if you try the
same move knight here you push it now we're going
to queen how do you stop the queen you got to go
here and then we zigzag right into checkmate here
right into queening followed by checkmate coming
right after very soon right it hurts to see it
as soon as he saw king to g3 shot oh my goodness
i can't believe this even happened what just
happened here i'm up a full piece now i'm losing
the game because there's nothing else
to do the only move in this position was
moving the knight to e6 and coming around and
ended up taking the pawn and settling for a
draw absolutely insane how this happened here it
was a huge blunder king c2 was just a blunder on
the spot king g3 wins on the spot nothing you can
do even bringing the king to either square we go
king f2 and we queen india anyway what a blunder
back in 1951 world championship david bronstein
versus mikhail boppinic and that was blunder
number three guys so now let's move on to world
championship blunder number four all right guys
now does this blunder look familiar to anyone
does anyone remember this position this was magnus
carlson versus vishwanathan anad back in 2014.
okay guys this is world championship match and
actually right here it's white to move fish one of
the neonatal not just went this she just went rook
to ga here rook d to ga and actually just putting
some pressure on the g file here now magnus for
thinking for a little bit actually plays this
move here king to d2 straight up blunder blunder
guys king to d2 is not a move here now what black
is supposed to do what do you mean supposed to do
didn't he make the move in the game no he didn't
he missed it does she not miss the winning move
here he actually plays a4 in the game in the game
the game he returned the favor here actually and
plays a4 but was what was supposed to happen that
could have ended the game very quickly guys in a
few moves here can you spot the move that vicious
and magnus carlsen both of them missed the
surprising tactic here that basically wins
the game you can go on to win the game from this
position what do you actually play here with black
this is what vichy missed he missed knight takes
e5 guys right here knight takes e5 bam what a shot
oh my goodness knight takes e5 it's a simple blow
but it ends the game on the spot well what's going
on why is 965 any winning isn't the knight hanging
absolutely it's hanging but your rook's hanging
you take my knight i take your rook that's an easy
win or how about you know maybe uh rook takes rook
first which is probably going to be the best line
rook takes rook then after uh knight takes c4
in in between move when inter meso or what they
call a jitsu at the same time knight takes c4
is checked so you have two moves king e2 or king
and d3 he too doesn't do anything i'm just going
to play take back on g8 now if king to d3 knight
to b2 check another in between move before coming
and taking the rook here king moves no matter
where you go i'm going to take on g8 and we're
going to go on to win this game with this hanging
of course we're up a little bit of material now
of course bishops versus knight here but this is
not what magnus wanted at all here now they both
missed it guys they absolutely both both missed
it here which is absolutely amazing and a4
a4 was actually the move played in the game
here guys but what a blunder missed by the
way by both of the world champions 100 percent
uh amazing here that even the best of the best
miss these type of shots all the time a4 was
played knight takes e5 was winning guys i remember
actually watching this and i was like knight takes
e5 i remember feeling it like that looks good and
he missed it and everyone around the world went
crazy that he missed vicious miss knight takes
e5 guys this was blunder number four and now we're
going to move on to the final world championship
blunder of today and here we are guys with blunder
number five world championship blunder number five
does anyone recognize this position very famous
very very famous position here if i give you five
seconds can you call this game who is playing this
game what world championship match is this one
here we go guys it is boris spassky versus
robert james fisher aka bobby fischer
back in 1972 here let's actually see what happened
now white plays b5 and actually just virtually an
equal game this should end up being a draw pawns
on both sides of the board same color bishop here
king's a slightly better place for white but
honestly objectively just a drawn position
with perfect play now what happened here is bobby
fischer just played the absolute the craziest move
you can see here we didn't understand it why was
it played but it was played it was a blunder 100
a blunder here guys here it is bishop
takes h2 he just takes the pawn
takes the pawn bishop takes h2 is not a move in
any way shape and form and after bishop takes h2
boris baskey just looks at him and looks
down at the board and looks back up at him
and then plays g3 your bishop is trapped
and then we're going to walk our king over
and take it now after h5 king 2 h4 king f3 king
e7 king g2 and the game's over take pawn take
pawn oh thank you thank you very much that's the
piece and boris baskey went on to win this game
amazing how we just blunder sometimes even the
best of the best make blunders now not all the
time they blunder way less than we do they're half
human and have something else from a different
chess planet but at the same time they still make
blunders here what a blunder by bobby fisher here
bishop takes h2 g3 and the game was virtually
over guys this is a famous blunder here guys
definitely do your research on this one check
out our chess.com articles on this one as well
and others world championship blunders as well
thank you so much for watching today's video
guys i'm national master james canty iii with
chess.com guys and i'll see you on the next video